it was a sad sad day when the countess
finally kicked the bucket
but the wealthy woman left a will in her
will she left all her money to her three
grandchildren despite the fact that they
were kind of spoiled brats the last line
of the will stated that she had one
final thing to give away a ruby the size
of a gosh-darn walnut holy hoo-ha
I want that walnut said the oldest
however the old woman only gave one clue
as to where that juicy ruby might be
located the ruby lies in a cylinder
surrounded by a thousand squares after a
long period of intense and fruitless
thought the youngest grandchild said I
know where it is she ran off and two
minutes later returned with that juicy
ruby where was it hidden I don't know
first of all why is grandma leaving
riddles in her will ain't nobody got
time for this this is really drew my
henna do I get more clues no can't be
her grave I can't be what is this again
maybe it's like a haunted house maybe
it's like in a funhouse or something
maybe I'm now I'm going all over the
place I'm too light a scope okay is
square are you talking about like you
know how people they'll call people
squares like you know they're not hip
inside a television inside her house I
don't know I have an idea yeah I give up
so where was the Ruby it was hidden in a
roll of toilet paper a cylinder
surrounded by a thousand squares give or
take a few oh my god this is what I was
thinking uh thug it's gonna be something
really simple isn't it oh my god